[Music]
hi and welcome this session will cover
top five ways to authenticate
applications to Google Cloud that don't
include downloading service account keys
my name is Busan I'm A Cloud consultant
based in South Korea here today with me
is Sean a product manager for workload
identity and service accounts based in
Sunnyvale
we'll start by introducing service
accounts and service account Keys then
we'll talk about the right way to
authenticate applications we'll end by
discussing best practices for managing
service account keys I'll cover the
first section and Sean will cover the
last two sections
before I talk about service accounts
I'll clarify what's in scope for today's
session first when we talk about apis in
this session we're referring to Google
Cloud API specifically authenticating to
other Google apis like the Google Maps
platform apis or the YouTube apis may
work differently second this session is
focused on programmatically
authenticating application code
third this session is targeted at
beginners we'll focus on the common
cases the goal is to give you an
overview of the available options our
documentation goes into much more detail
on what to consider and how to use
specific authentication methods
now I'll introduce service accounts and
service account keys
Google Cloud apis require every API call
to be authorized in other words apis
require calls to identify who is making
the call this feeds into audit logs
quota and billing there are three ways
to authorize API calls first is API keys
this only identifies the application API
keys are a string of letters and numbers
API keys aren't an option for the
majority of apis but apis that support
it include the natural language API and
the translate API second option is a
user account this is an end human user
accessing resources an example might be
me creating a Google compute engine
instance through Google Cloud console or
gcloud
the third option is a service account
which is an identity that represents a
workload or an application application
code is most likely using a service
account
again surface accounts represent an
application or compute workload rather
than a human user a public-private RSA
key pair is used for authentication
there are no passwords so you can't log
in as a service account via the browser
service account identities also don't
belong to the Google workspace domain
there are two types of service accounts
the first is a service account that you
make for your own applications there are
also default service accounts created
when you use certain services for
example when you create a compute
instance in a brand new project the
compute engine default service account
is created and attached to the instance
for your production workloads we
recommend you create custom service
accounts tailored for the workload
rather than relying on the default
service accounts
when using a service account you have
the option to download a service account
Json file this is the private key for
the service account however we don't
recommend downloading key files if you
can avoid doing so that's because there
are some risks associated with using
service count Keys the first is
credential leakage consider the scenario
where a developer accidentally commits a
key to a public code repository that
actor can get access to the resources in
your environment using that key file
second risk is privilege escalation if a
bad actor gets access to a service
account key they might be able to use
the key to escalate their own privileges
for example the bad actor could use a
service account with permissions Google
Cloud Storage bucket to give themselves
additional privileges on the bucket the
third risk is identity masking when a
bad actor acts through a service account
key they can conceal their identity and
actions since API calls are recorded as
having been made through the service
account the main takeaway of this slide
is that anyone with the service account
Json file can make API calls as that
service account
since you now understand some risks of
using service account key files Sean
will share how we recommend you
authenticate your applications
thank you Busan as explained above there
are a lot of risk and security issues
related to using service account Keys we
are seeing a lot of customers and
developers who are authenticating with
these Keys when they should be using
alternative methods today I am going to
focus on these alternative methods as
well as what you should consider if you
must use a service account key
because there are multiple ways to
authenticate to Google Cloud's API as an
application we built out a flow diagram
to help you decide on which method to
use based on different situations
we will first go through the diagram
before jumping into the details of each
of the authentication methods
the first question that you always need
to ask yourself is whether your
application is running on Google cloud
or not this is the first part of the
flow diagram
if the application is running on Google
Cloud then you want to check are you
trying to run your application on gke or
outside of gke for gke there is a
special feature called gke workload
identity which is a simple way for you
to Federate in your kubernetes service
account to get a gcp access token if it
is not on gke then we have two methods
if you're doing development work in
local environments then we recommend
gcloud auth application default login
well if it isn't in running a local
environment then we recommend attaching
a service account directly to your
compute or serverless instances on
Google Cloud
shifting to the other side of the tree
you want to ask yourself if your app is
not running on Google cloud is it
possible to set up Federation
you are able to set up workflow and the
Federation for workloads running in
other Cloud as well as on-premise as
long as the cloud providers or your
on-premise deployment have the ability
to generate an ID token if that is not
possible then you are left with service
account key which should be the last
result I will spend the last part of
today's session going through a few
methods you can use to secure your
service account keys but before going
there I'm going to go a little more
detail into each of these authentication
methods the first method I want to focus
on is gcloud application default login
most folks who use gcloud are familiar
with gcloud auth login which allows you
to log into gcloud via the command line
this is very similar to gcloud auth
login however instead of signing in to
run methods on the command line This
Will generate a user credential for the
user who is running the command it will
then automatically put the credential in
the well-known location for application
default credentials for the client
Library which means as long as you use
client libraries in your application to
make requests to gcp API it will
automatically fetch this credential and
use it to make requests to gcp API this
is very secure and time-bound credential
which is perfect for local development
note that in this case you're not even
using a service account you're just
using the credential of your user login
now if we move away from local
development onto workflows on gcp
including serverless products like app
engine Cloud run Cloud functions or
compute products like compute engine
then the best and only way you should be
using to access gcp API is using
attached service accounts when you
create a GCE VM most times as Busan
mentioned it will automatically come
with a default service account we
recommend you to create a service
account based on applications that you
are running and replace the default
service account with this new service
account
not only will the attached service
account Grant the application ability to
authenticate without using a key the
custom created service account will also
make sure you adhere to the principle of
least privilege when it comes to calling
gcpa API you can similarly use the
client Library exactly like in the
previous slide
and in the previous example and the
client libraries will help figure out
how to retrieve the service accounts and
its permissions to perform the API
requests
we are seeing a lot of developers and
customers who are using service account
keys for the scenario especially because
Legacy tutorials floating around on the
internet
tells people to do so please make sure
to never use a service account key when
running on any of these gcp Services if
a set of other gcp resources you're
running your workloads specifically on
gke we recommend you to go check how gke
workload identity the process is
streamlined and all you need to do is
enable gke workload identity and make
sure that you have configured your
kubernetes service account inside your
clusters gke workload identity will
automatically exchange your kubernetes
token for a gcp service account token in
order to authenticate as the gcp service
account once you set this up you should
be able to allow your workload to
directly access gcp apis
finally for applications running
completely outside of Google Cloud for
example if your application is running
on AWS Azure on-prem or GitHub gitlab we
recommend you to use workload identity
Federation
as long as your workload has the ability
to generate an identity token for itself
in its native environment local identity
Federation allows you to exchange the
native ID token for gcp Access token
with the gcp access token you will be
able to impersonate a regular service
account and its permission without using
a service account key this is very
similar to the gke workflow identity
flow the only difference is that you
will have to set up the Federation pool
yourself based on whichever cloud
provider or SAS service or on-prem
service that you're trying to integrate
into gcp API
if you're using our client libraries
most of the credential exchange flow is
fully automated and taken care of by our
client libraries workload identity
Federation is very popular and much more
secure than using service account Keys
we have put in a lot of effort to make
the experience more seamless for our
customers recently we added Integrations
with gcloud gsuto and BQ CLI to enable
more use cases with these Federated
identities for customers who have apps
running on premise with on-premise
identity providers we also launched
Samuel support as well as the ability to
retrieve IDP tokens via a customer
defined executable through the client
Library this is very important if
especially if you're trying to connect
your on-premise application to gcp API
that is because each of your on-premise
identity provider might have different
ways in which to retrieve the
credentials and allowing you to write
your own executable will dramatically
simplify the process of retrieving the
credential and exchanging it for gcp
Access token
now that we went through the recommended
authentication methods there are still
scenarios where you must use a service
account key and for these scenarios I'm
going to give some recommendations to
help you best secure your service
account and your service account keys
first of all you should prefer to always
upload Keys over downloading service
account keys
this is a native feature attached to
service accounts you can use your own
pki infrastructure to generate a public
private keep here and deliver the
private Keys securely to your runtime
environment
public Keys which on the other hand are
less dangerous to be handled and passed
around can be uploaded to Google Cloud
this way there's less chance for error
when it comes to handling and passing
around private keys
secondly for scenarios where you need to
access gcp API from non-production
applications for example if you have an
intern building a proof of concept or
you're manually triggering some jobs to
retrieve data for your data SAS Services
we recently previewed the ability for
you to set up exploration time on your
service account key configuring
expiration at the project folder or
organization level will make sure that
any Keys generated under that container
will automatically have a key generated
with that the expiration time attached
note however that we don't recommend key
expiration in production environment as
it is very easy for developers to put
that into the code and when it expires
it leads to outages and that is
something that we want to help our
customers to avoid
to prevent outages I want to finally
talk about key rotation and this might
be something that you might have heard
about before but what you want to make
sure is that every developer in your
organization gets into the habit of
rotating these service count Keys due to
all the security risks that we discussed
using tools like Cloud asset inventory
you'll be able to track down when each
key has been created you can then build
custom toolings based on your
organization structure to trigger
notification to development teams to go
and rotate these Keys you can rotate you
can configure this notifications to get
louder over time if they're not act upon
alternatively you can test out tools
like terraform vault which will also
help simplify the process of rotating
these Keys although the process is
complicated if service account key is a
must in parts of your organization we
highly recommend you to set up proper
rotation policies to prevent any
security issues linked to these service
account keys long-lived service account
key is one of the biggest issues when it
comes to Cloud security and we hope this
presentation was useful for you and your
organization
thank you Busan for joining us today and
thank you all for listening and helping
to think about how we can together make
the cloud more secure
[Music]